В ефірі «heute journal»
з Крістіаном Зіверсом і Ханною Ціммерман.
Доброго вечора всім.
Не можна допустити
поширення війни проти України на інші країни,
за жодних обставин ми не повинні
бути прямо втягнуті
і стати стороною війни.
Це мантра уряду Німеччини,
актуальні сподівання громадян
і водночас дуже серйозна небезпека.
Причина – російський ексклав Калінінград,
колишній Кеніґсберґ,
всього 500 км від Берліну.
Зараз там загострюється конфлікт
між Росією та Литвою,
йдеться  про санкції ЄС та погрози Росії.
Щоб зрозуміти, наскільки «гаряча» ця тема,
розпочнемо з огляду від Лаури Барнік.
Кінець Другої світової війни.
За угодою в Потсдамській конференції Сталін домігся,
щоб Кеніґсберґ увійшов до складу Радянського Союзу,
а не окупованої Литви.
Після розпаду Радянського Союзу
російський ексклав так і лишився -
відділений від основної території Росії регіон,
оточений іншими державами.
Свою нинішню назву Калінінград отримав у 1946 році
на честь радянського партійного діяча
Михайла Калініна,
який помер у тому ж році.
Калінінград розташований між Литвою і Польщею
і забезпечує Росії стратегічно
важливий вихід до Балтійського моря.
В часи Холодної війни портове місто
стало місцем базування
Балтійського флоту Росії
і таким чином своєрідною
фортецею Росії в центрі Європи.
НАТО занепокоєно спостерігає за Калінінградом,
що пов'язано, зокрема і з Сувальським коридором,
територією між Білоруссю та Калінінградською областю,
яка відділяєЛитву відПольщі.
Сувальський коридор завдовжки лише 65,4 км,
але це «ахіллесова п'ята» НАТО.
Литва обмежила пропуск транзиту вантажів, які
проходять з Росії до Калінінграду через Литву,
в межах виконання санкцій ЄС.
Росія відкрито погрожує «серйозними наслідками».
Це матиме наслідки і для нас,
оскільки Литва є нашим партнером в ЄС і НАТО.
Детальніше - Наталі Штеґер.
Дуже особливий прикордонний трикутник,
це вид з території Польщі,
вже по ту сторону невеликий ліс належить Литві,
а за зеленим парканом російський Калінінград.
Ми живемо прямо на кордоні і розуміємо,
що будемо першими, хто зазнає нападу.
Іноді в мене виникають такі думки.
Життя на Сувальському коридорі,
між Калінінградом і Білоруссю.
У разі військового конфлікту
Росія може спробувати ізолювати країни Балтії,
дуже вразливі зі стратегічного погляду.
Тут ми маємо прямий контакт
з кордоном Російської Федерації,
і тут точно достатньо місця,
щоб танкові колони легко могли пройти.
За російськими даними, Москва розмістила
в Калінінграді ракети «Іскандер»
з ядерною бойовою частиною.
І ось зараз спір саме через Калінінград.
Литва більше не дозволяє через свою територію
вивозити до російського ексклаву
такі товари як метал, сталь і будматеріали,
які раніше доставлялися залізницею до Калінінграду
з Росії через Литву.
Наразі у Калінінграді запасаються будматеріалами.
Можливо, ціни зростуть
або ми не зможемо купувати продукти,
до яких звикли.
40-50% товарів скоро зникне з полиць,-
каже губернатор Калінінграда, а з Москви чути погрози.
Найближчим часом будуть розроблені
і вжиті відповідні заходи на рівні міністерств.
Вони матимуть серйозні негативні наслідки
для населення Литви.
Військовий напад Росії на одну з країн НАТО
вважається малоймовірним.
Ми можемо очікувати «важкої» дипломатії,
суворої риторики, можливо жорстких провокацій,
як-от порушення повітряного простору.
Сьогодні Путін не сказав
жодного слова про Калінінград,
тільки те, що він зміцнюватиме збройні сили
у зв'язку з можливою загрозою.
Литву не лякає суперечка
щодо транзиту до Калінінграда.
Ми виконуємо санкції ЄС.
Литва не зацікавлена в ескалації.
Але є санкції і вони мають бути реалізовані.
Суперечка в стратегічно чутливій точці,
що також має особливе значення для Берліну.
Німеччина очолює місію НАТО в Литві
і нещодавно посилила свою залученість
як стримуючий фактор.
У ці часи для мене важливо прояснити одне:
Німеччина твердо стоїть
на боці Литви та всіх наших східних союзників.
Віднині Росія хоче доставляти
більше товарів до Калінінграда морським шляхом.
Транзитний спір - це ще один
конфлікт між Росією та ЄС.
Поки назріває новий сценарій конфлікту,
уряд Німеччини
несподівано змінює свою стратегію комунікації.
Точний список німецьких поставок зброї
в Україну тепер доступний в Інтернеті.
І співголова SPD змушує замислитися,
оскільки те, що він каже, є переломним моментом
не тільки для його партії.
Ларс Клінґбайль бачить Німеччину у новій ролі -
у ролі, цитата, «провідної держави».
Детальніше - Клаус Бродбек з Берліну.
Так буває, коли впевненість та звички
раптом виявляються малозначущими,
тому що сьогодення вимагає іншого.
SPD і переломний момент.
Час змін вимагатиме від нас багато чого.
Потрясіння вплинуть на наше спільне життя,
на політику і суспільство
у найближчі 10-15-20 років.
Клінґбайль коригує курс своєї партії,
а отже, можливо, і країни,
відійшовши від зовнішньополітичної скромності
минулих десятиліть.
Німеччина повинна претендувати
на роль великої держави.
Після майже 80 років стриманості
Німеччина має нову роль
в міжнародній системі координат.
За останні десятиліття Німеччина
заслужила високий ступінь довіри,
і ця довіра йде пліч-о-пліч з очікуваннями.
Сьогодні відомство канцлера змінює курс:
замість секретності - прозорість.
Відтепер відомство публікуватиме
найактуальнішу інформацію про те,
що Німеччина надала і ще надасть Україні -
боєприпаси, танки, а також
довгоочікувані самохідні гаубиці типу Panzerhaubitze 2000,
які нарешті прибули сьогодні в Україну,
про що захоплено повідомив міністр оборони України
в Twitter: «вони зададуть жару в бою».
Увечері консервативна група партії SPD «Seeheimer Kreis»
здійснила традиційний щорічний «спаржевий круїз»
озером Ванзеє, до якого долучився
канцлер, який пояснює зміни однопартійцям.
«Ми вирішили змінити курс з вагомих причин.
Це сміливе рішення і воно матиме далекосяжні наслідки.
Я вдячний за те, що це рішення підтримали.
Всі ми відчуваємо однаково: це зараз необхідно,
ось чому ми це робимо».
Але без сумнівів не обійдеться, це добре видно,
також і всередині партії SPD.
Шакунтало Бенерджі,
нова зовнішня і безпекова політика Німеччини,
Німеччина як провідна держава.
Чи є те, що вимагає співголова SPD,
закликом до його партії?
SPD не є партією
з радикальними пацифістськими поглядами,
але в минулому їй було нелегко на дебатах
щодо нової ролі Німеччини в зовнішній і безпековій політиці,
зокрема щодо участі у військових операціях.
У Берліні гучно критикували нерішучість канцлера
у питанні підтримки України,
вбачаючи причини нерішучості саме в позиції SPD.
Співголова SPD Ларс Клінґбайль
заявляє про переломний момент,
спираючись на раніше проголошений канцлером
«час змін», і схвалює новий курс канцлера.
Для партії - це виклик, оскільки Клінґбайль говорить
про військову силу як частину політики миру.
Поки що невідомо, чи партія підтримає такий курс,
але дискусія відкрита.
Нова стратегія комунікації щодо поставок зброї:
навіщо вона, якщо уряд Німеччини
завжди відмовлявся говорити відкрито,
посилаючись на секретність?
Уряд пояснює це пристосуванням
до практики США як найближчого союзника,
хоча варто сказати,
що ніхто не заважав зробити це раніше.
Очевидно, уряд хоче вийти з позиції «оборони»,
відійти від критики щодо незрозумілих і повільних поставок,
коли неясно, в який час і що доставлять.
Дуже доречною є поставка самохідних гаубиць,
які вже прибули в Україну,
якраз перед завтрашньою урядовою заявою канцлера
і звітуванням міністерки оборони
перед депутатами парламенту.
Шакунтало, дякую за аналіз!
Трохи згодом, у випуску «heute journal up: date»,
Ґундула Ґаузе поставить запитання
на цю тему Родеріхові Кізеветеру,
експерту з питань оборони від CDU.
Сьогодні в Німеччині День промисловості,
і  цього дня можна помітити багато стурбованих облич.
Федеральна асоціація
німецької промисловості (BDI)
сьогодні запрошує потужну групу інтересів
і промислове лобі
на свій день - щорічну
«урочисту месу BDI», як пишуть у газетах.
Й насправді політична верхівка
приходить туди як на прощу
й мусить слухати про великі занепокоєння.
Очільник BDI говорить про «подвійну кризу».
Склалася майже парадоксальна ситуація.
З одного боку - багато замовлень
й активне використання виробничих потужностей,
з іншого - похмурі перспективи.
Економічні прогнози
Асоціації німецької промисловості
різко погіршилися.
Більше розповість Елізабет Шмідт.
Зазвичай тут влаштовують концерти та вечірки.
Концертна зала в Берліні сьогодні заповнена
провідними представниками
німецької промисловості.
Але замість святкового настрою -
біль на «ахіллесовій п’яті» промисловості.
Енергопостачання
досі залежить від російського газу.
Без енергії зупиниться промислове виробництво,
Це - проблема, створена і «власними руками».
Ми заощадили на пожежній охороні,
адже вважали, що немає значної
пожежної небезпеки.
А зараз всюди пожежі.
Тому пакети фінансової підтримки
були загалом правильною ідеєю.
Однак це рішення не на довгу перспективу.
Парадоксальна ситуація: підприємства мають
вдосталь замовлень,
однак представники галузі цілком відкрито
говорять про загрозу рецесії.
Асоціація промисловості змінила прогнози
темпів розвитку економіки
з 3,5% на початок року до теперішніх 1,5%.
Проблеми з ланцюгом постачання,
дефіцит сировини, енергетична криза -
промисловці сподіваються отримати фінансову
підтримку від уряду Німеччини,
який сьогодні спершу похвалив себе.
До 2030 року 80% наших потреб в електроенергії
і 50% у теплі мають задовольняти
відновні джерела енергії.
Так, крок за кроком, наша країна прийде
до незалежності від викопних енергоносіїв
і коливань цін на енергію.
Однак уряд Німеччини теж
поставив вимоги до промисловості.
Промисловці повинні пришвидшити
перехід на відновні джерела енергії.
Однак представники Союзу CDU/CSU
вважають, що вже запізно.
Вони пропонують
повернутися до джерел енергії,
від яких уже давно відмовилися.
Нам необхідно розглянути можливість
залучити три атомні електростанції,
які ще можуть бути запущені в Німеччині.
Пані та панове, вже принаймні кілька днів
ми знаємо про те,
що це можливо як з технічної,
так і юридичної точки зору.
Три атомні електростанції наразі становлять
приблизно 6%
від енергопостачання Німеччини.
Для порівняння: 15% електроенергії
отримують з природного газу.
Перейти на ядерну енергетику складно,
а через рішення до кінця року відмовитися
від ядерної енергетики
вже не лишиться паливних стрижнів.
Але прихильники ядерної енергетики заспокоюють.
Вживши певних заходів, ми могли б продовжити
використання наявних
паливних елементів на кілька місяців.
За певних обставин може
з'явитися часова прогалина,
поки нові паливні елементи
не будуть готові до використання.
Але до зими 2023/24, ймовірно, вдасться
запустити системи на повну потужність
з новими паливними елементами.
Ядерна енергетика завжди була
екологічнішою за природний газ.
Проте міністр економіки з партії Зелених
покладається на вугільні електростанції -
неохоче, але зважаючи на вимоги часу.
Через скрутне становище нам необхідно
знову залучати й випустити на ринок
більше викопного палива,
ніж ми насправді хотіли.
Однак це неминучий крок, адже йдеться
про необхідність уникнути важкої економічної кризи
для німецького суспільства.
Наскільки урядові Німеччини
важливі його принципи
та де взяти мільярди євро
на уникнення економічної кризи -
залишається ще багато питань.
І щодня їх стає дедалі більше.
З нами на зв'язку Крістіан Лінднер,
міністр фінансів Німеччини.
Добрий вечір, пане Лінднер.
Добрий вечір.
Німецькі промисловці мають багато замовлень,
однак перспективи спричиняють занепокоєння.
Чи не тому це відбувається,
що в країні якісь величезні проблеми?
Так, є небезпека розвитку
серйозної економічної кризи
через зростання цін на енергоносії,
проблеми з ланцюгами постачання,
а також інфляцію.
Тому наразі найважливішим завданням має бути
вживання усіх можливих заходів
в економічній і фінансовій політиці
задля зупинки інфляції.
Це важливо не лише через економіку,
але й тому, що багато людей хвилюються за те,
чи матимуть вони гроші на життя.
Чи означає це, що президент Росії
контролює нас більше,
ніж нам хотілося б?
Так, ми маємо величезні економічні наслідки,
але ні, Путін не контролює нас.
Лише ми є архітекторами власного майбутнього.
Ми можемо диверсифікувати енергопостачання,
знайти у світі інші джерела.
налагодити інші ланцюги постачання,
провадити вільну торгівлю з іншими країнами
й у такий спосіб відкрити для себе
нові економічні перспективи.
Також ми можемо залучити власні ресурси
для енергопостачання.
Наприклад, наші родовища газу й нафти
зараз набагато рентабельніші,
ніж кілька місяців тому
внаслідок зростання цін на світовому ринку.
Нам не потрібно мати жодних «мисленнєвих табу»,
табу щодо нових пропозицій,
коли йдеться про контроль
динаміки цін для населення.
Гаразд, поговорімо про «мисленнєві табу».
Ймовірно, нам варто очікувати,
принаймні за словами деяких аналітиків,
найбільшої з 1945 року економічної кризи.
Ви щойно сказали про рекордні ціни на енергоносії,
а це екзистенційні питання.
Проте відповіді, які дає урядова коаліція,
кардинально суперечать одна одній.
Чи це зараз потрібно Німеччині?
Де відповіді кардинально суперечать одна одній?
Наприклад, Ви стверджуєте, що Німеччина
може залучити власні ресурси,
видобувати власні енергоносії.
Припускаю, під цим Ви маєте на увазі фрекінг.
Партія FDP пропонує
дозволити довше використовувати
ядерні електростанції.
SPD і Зелені, тобто Ваші партнери по коаліції,
відкидають обидва варіанти.
Це і є Ваш антикризовий план, пане Лінднер?
Це треба принаймні обговорити.
Мене бентежить те, що за кілька тижнів і місяців
ми можемо опинитися в дуже тривожній ситуації.
І в цій ситуації ми не повинні бути вибагливими.
Йдеться про 3-5 років дефіциту.
Нам потрібно мати план на цей випадок.
Один варіант - це розвиток
відновних джерел енергії.
З цим усі погоджуються.
Інший варіант - імпорт зрідженого газу.
Для цього нам наразі необхідні плавучі термінали,
судна, які можуть подавати його
в нашу газову мережу.
Як міністр фінансів я виділив на це кошти.
Потім нам потрібно прискорити планування,
щоб це можна було реалізувати,
ми всі з цим погоджуємося.
Правда полягає в тому,
що ми маємо також інші варіанти.
Ми маємо родовища нафти й газу
в Північному морі й на суші,
а також три атомні електростанції
в робочому стані,
і я вважаю, що необхідно обговорювати,
чи ці варіанти можуть бути використані
на перехідний період.
Ціни на газ та енергоносії зростають
так сильно, що я...
Звісно, це необхідно обговорювати,
але на цю мить Ви радше сперечаєтеся про це,
тож наразі немає жодного результату.
Так, це правда.
Наразі в нас немає обопільної згоди,
та ми не сперечаємося.
Не кожен обмін думками
автоматично є суперечкою.
І я не налаштований щось вимагати.
Так, ми хочемо продовжити роботу
ядерних електростанцій.
Але я залюбки розгляну всі аргументи
й альтернативні пропозиції.
У будь-якому разі, мене не влаштовує перспектива
продовжувати роботу
неекологічних вугільних електростанцій
і навіть не розглядати потенціал
ядерної енергетики.
І саме це я хотів би змінити.
Цю можливість необхідно принаймні
розглянути на найближче майбутнє
без ідеологічних міркувань, враховуючи
неймовірне зростання цін.
Припускаю, що люди теж
очікують цього від політиків.
Пане Лінднер, стимулювання промислових підприємств,
а також приватних споживачів відмовитися від газу -
вже коштуватиме чималих грошей.
Ваших грошей, відповідно й наших грошей,
які Ви витрачаєте на нас.
Наразі у надзвичайних ситуаціях
через пандемію призупинено
механізм обмеження державного боргу.
Чому й не зараз, у цій надзвичайній ситуації?
2022 року обмеження боргу призупинено.
Ми щойно ухвалили пакет фінансової допомоги
на понад 30 млрд євро.
Передусім йдеться про підтримку населення:
фінансова допомога на виховання дитини,
одноразова виплата на енергоносії,
зниження відрахування за відновну енергію...
Боргами ми також фінансуємо
термінали зрідженого природного газу.
Тож я тут не притримуюся жорстких догм.
Видатки фінансуються, коли це необхідно.
Однак держава також є жертвою інфляції.
Відсотки, які мені треба платити з Ваших грошей,
наступного року зростуть до 30 млрд євро.
Торік їх було 4 млрд, цього року - 30 млрд.
Це дуже чіткий сигнал політикам про те,
що ми не можемо продовжувати
нашу боргову політику.
Точніше кажучи, ми вже не можемо
собі дозволити більше боргів,
адже держава тепер платить високі відсотки.
Гаразд, пане Лінднер,
але цього року Ваші нові борги
становлять понад 200 млрд євро.
Тож, якщо Ви дотримуєтесь
обмеження боргу наступного року,
то нові борги становитимуть
максимум 7,5 млрд євро.
Це ж повне фінансове гальмування,
і Ви хочете це зробити посеред цієї
важкої екзистенційної кризи?
Ні, не зовсім так.
Цього року їх було 139 млрд, наступного року...
Плюс 100 млрд на Збройні сили.
Так, це буде в наступні роки,
а цього року їх 139 млрд, а активи Бундесверу,
тобто Спеціальний фонд для Бундесверу - пізніше,
наступного року близько 10 млрд євро.
Однак вже не буде деяких спеціальних витрат
через пандемію.
І все ж я не хочу применшувати
серйозність завдання.
Воно вимагає величезних зусиль для консолідації,
але ми повинні це зробити.
Це не моя примха, мені теж не подобається
казати іншим міністрам,
що цей план не працює.
Найперший шлях боротьби з інфляцією
полягає в тому,
що держава знижує тиск на ціни.
Якщо держава виплачує дедалі більше субсидій,
стимулює зростання цін грошима з податків,
ми ніколи не впораємося з інфляцією.
Завдання полягає в тому,
щоб вилізти з боргів,
планомірно і прицільно полегшувати становище людей,
не залишати їх наодинці з інфляцією,
а потім знизити тиск на ціни,
забезпечивши інші форми
стимулювання економічного зростання.
Наприклад, дебюрократизація економіки.
На зв'язку був міністр фінансів Німеччини
Крістіан Лінднер з партії FDP.
Дякую за інтерв'ю.
Дякую.
Про ситуацію в Україні розповість Ханна.
На сході та півдні країни сьогодні тривали бої.
Як повідомив голова Харківської ОДА,
внаслідок обстрілу російськими ракетами
на Харківщині загинули 15 людей.
Також повідомлялося про тяжкі бої в Сєвєродонецьку.
За словами голови Луганської ОДА,
у промзоні міста велися
масовані артилерійські і ракетні обстріли.
CDU та Зелені в Шлезвіґ-Гольштайні
успішно завершили коаліційні переговори.
Про це заявив прем'єрміністр землі Даніель Ґюнтер.
Завтра обидві партії прокоментують
деталі коаліційної угоди.
На початку наступного тижня обидві партії
ще мають затвердити угоду на партійних з'їздах,
однак «за», певно, проголосує більшість,
як і за переобрання Даніеля Ґюнтера прем'єрміністром.
Згідно з ухвалою Європейського суду,
країни ЄС можуть продовжувати зберігати
дані авіапасажирів,
але в майбутньому їх можна буде обробляти
лише в обмеженому обсязі,
а саме в обсязі,
необхідному для боротьби з тероризмом.
Це стосується усіх рейсів до та з країн ЄС.
Крім того, країнам-членам дозволятиметься
зберігати дані лише протягом 6 місяців﻿,
а не 5 років, як це було раніше.
Найдовше можуть зберігатися лише дані про осіб,
які пов'язані зі скоєнням
небезпечних кримінальних злочинів.
Виставка «documenta» у Касселі є, напевно,
найважливішою міжнародною виставкою
сучасного мистецтва.
Але вона також спричиняє дискусії,
обурення та суперечки.
Завжди.
Здивування та несподіванки - їх завжди
варто очікувати від виставки.
Але тепер навколо виставки точиться суперечка,
яка виходить далеко за межі простого здивування.
Мер міста каже:
«Я злий, розчарований, ображений».
Передусім виникає безліч питань
до організаторів виставки.
Твір мистецтва, що став предметом
запеклих суперечок та критики
через масові звинувачення в антисемітизмі,
тепер приберуть.
Детальніше - Петер Тайзен.
Зображення, з якого почалася суперечка:
замість обличчя - голова свині
із написом «Моссад»
на позначення спецслужби Ізраїлю.
Клішовані, зневажливі алюзії на євреїв -
зображення, які бентежать багатьох відвідувачів
виставки «documenta».
Я думаю, що це виходить за межі дозволеного,
бо це стигматизація єврейського народу загалом.
Варто пам'ятати, що ми тут, у Німеччині.
І це виставка,
яка виходить на міжнародний рівень саме з цієї країни.
Я вважаю, що таке не можна дозволяти.
Робота індонезійської групи митців «Taring Padi»,
яку створили 20 років тому,
виставили лише на цих вихідних.
Вчора художники прокоментували цю роботу.
«Усі зображені фігури стосуються символіки,
поширеної в політичному контексті Індонезії,
наприклад, корумповане правління,
військові генерали та їхні солдати
зображені подібними до свиней, собак та щурів,
як критика експлуататорської капіталістичної системи
та військового насильства».
Цей коментар Центральна рада євреїв не схвалює.
Щоразу, коли звинувачення в антисемітизмі
висувається творам мистецтва, книгам, будь-чому,
одразу вмикається захисний рефлекс.
Кажуть: «Це не те, що я (ми) мали на увазі».
Ми бачимо чіткі антисемітські зображення
на цьому полотні,
тому мені важко зрозуміти, чому митці
так виправдовуються.
Директорка виставки «documenta»,
перебуваючи під тиском,
сьогодні перепросила за кураторів з Індонезії.
Разом з кураторами «Ruangrupa»,
мистецьким колективом, художниками та художницями
ми запевнили, що на виставці «documenta 15»
не буде творів з антисемітським змістом.
Інакше ми негайно втрутилися б.
На жаль, ми не дотрималися цієї обіцянки,
і цього не мало статися.
Я хочу встановити, як таке могло трапитися,
а потім ми маємо переконатися та перевірити,
що надалі не буде жодних подібних творів
та жодних ﻿виставкових форматів
з антисемітським змістом.
Після бурхливих протестів
учора експонат завісили.
Сьогодні ввечері його мають повністю прибрати
з виставки.
Але дискусія про антисемітизм
на виставці «documenta» залишається.
Про новини економіки розповість Ханна.
Велика поразка для концерну «Bayer».
Верховний суд США сьогодні відхилив
апеляцію компанії у справі,
що стосувалася обвинувачення
у використанні гліфосату.
Запитаємо у Зіни Майніц, що на зв'язку з Франкфурта,
що саме рішення Верховного суду означає
для компанії «Bayer»?
Відхилення апеляції Верховним судом США
не є несподіванкою, але це ще одна поразка
для компанії «Bayer»
у скандалі щодо гербіциду гліфосату.
Позивачі звинувачують компанію у тому,
що гліфосат є канцерогеном,
але компанія це заперечує.
Триває судовий процес, що завдає шкоди
репутації концерну,
а інвестори вважають колишнє придбання
компанії «Monsanto» помилкою.
У червні 2018 року компанія «Bayer»
придбала американський концерн,
який виготовляє гліфосат «Раундап».
На придбання компанія «Bayer» витратила
60 млрд доларів США.
Відтоді ціна акцій «Bayer» впала на 34%.
Але скандал з гліфосатом
спричиняє й інші труднощі для концерну
зі штаб-квартирою у Леверкузені.
Тим часом компанія «Bayer»
відклала кілька мільярдів євро на судовий процес.
У майбутньому компанія хоче ﻿безпосередньо
та у позасудовому порядку
врегулювати питання з потенційними позивачами.
З наступного року гліфосат більше не продаватимуть
садівникам-любителям,
а лише професійному сільськогосподарському сектору.
Чотири роки судових суперечок через гліфосат
підривають непогані показники
фармацевтичного та хімічного гіганта з Леверкузена.
І, ймовірно, так триватиме ще якийсь час.
Багато неприємностей,
яких компанія «Bayer» могла б уникнути.
Зіно, дякую за це пояснення.
Майже через 5 місяців після того,
як застрелили двох правоохоронців
поблизу міста Кузель,
розпочався суд над підозрюваним у вбивстві.
Суд звинувачує 39-річного злочинця
у подвійному вбивстві.
Сьогодні злочинець заявив, що стріляв не він один:
його ймовірний спільник застрелив
жінку-поліцейського.
Він також повідомив, що діяв із метою самооборони.
Наприкінці січня під час дорожнього патрулювання
у нічну зміну
було вбито стажерку-поліцейського та її колегу,
імовірно з метою приховання браконьєрства.
Німецька метеорологічна служба попереджає
про сильні грози зі штормовими вітрами,
зливами та градом
у південній Баварії та Баден-Вюртемберзі.
А зараз про чемпіонат світу з плавання в Будапешті
та третю медаль для Німеччини.
Флоріан Веллброк завоював срібну медаль
на дистанції 800 метрів вільним стилем.
Зробив він це у рекордний для Німеччини час.
Випередив його лише американець Роберт Фінк.
Партнер Веллброка із тренувань
українець Михайло Романчук завоював «бронзу».
Яка чудова історія!
Після нас в ефірі репортаж «37 Grad»,
який завжди вартий перегляду:
історія трьох учнів та учениць із випускного класу
загальноосвітньої школи Кельна.
Репортаж про боротьбу з упередженнями,
про випускний іспит та перехід
на наступний етап життя.
Залишайтесь з нами та насолоджуйтесь
останніми годинами цього дня.
Довших днів цього року вже не буде.
Бажаємо Вам гарного вечора.
До побачення.
Ласкаво просимо до перегляду прогнозу погоди.
Сьогодні - найдовший день року.
І метеорологи всього світу у цей день
переглядають «теплові смуги».
2018 року Ед Гокінс хотів у такий простий спосіб
зобразити глобальне потепління.
Кожна смуга показує, чи той чи інший рік
був теплішим чи холоднішим порівняно
з середніми показниками.
Взято період з 1850 до 2021 року.
І чітко видно, як сильно підвищилися температури
з 1980 року.
А тепер щодо погоди.
Холодний фронт приніс на південь країни
вологе повітря та нестійку погоду.
Саме через це сьогодні ввечері та вночі
на південному заході
пройдуть зливи та грози, подекуди сильні.
На півночі ясно, температура знизиться до 7-12°.
На півдні - передгрозове повітря,
але буде трохи тепліше - 13-18°.
Завтра на узбережжях приблизно 20°,
в інших областях літні температури - 25-30°.
На півночі буде сонячно.
Лише у Шлезвіґ-Гольштайні буде похмура погода
через сильний туман.
Однак на півдні, в Саарланді,
південній частині Рейнланд-Пфальца,
Баварії та Баден-Вюртемберзі
знову очікуються зливи та грози.
Зливи та грози йтимуть впродовж ночі та ранку,
а потім - в другий половині дня, але вже сильніші.
Також подекуди можливі сильні дощі,
град та шквали.
З четверга очікується спекотна літня погода.
У п'ятницю - грози на заході.
Гарного вечора!